es ist soweit die gezielte suche nach
außerirdischen hat begonnen nachdem mit
treppen zum ersten mal ein system in
unserer nähe mit sieben erdähnlichen
planeten entdeckt wurde wird dort jetzt
nachlegen das allen telescope array hat
seine radioteleskope auf das system
gerichtet um dort signale abzufangen
noch nie waren die chancen so gut
außerirdisches leben zu finden
warum das so ist und warum die nasa
meint dass wir schon bald elian sind
werden das jetzt in kriegs und science
fiction herzlich willkommen
vor drei jahren kündigt der nasa
direktor charles boden an in den
nächsten 20 jahren werden wir aliens
finden und der zeitpunkt scheint jetzt
deutlich näher zu rücken nicht nur das
nächstes jahr zwei alien missionen
staaten auch schon jetzt können die
nachforschung intensiviert werden der
status im jahr 2018 wird die nasa zwei
missionen staaten die gezielt nach
außerirdischen suchen werden
zum einen ist es die transit in
exoplanet service satellit mission test
also die suche nach vorbeiziehenden
exoplaneten
das prinzip ist dabei ganz einfach zieht
ein planet an einem stern vorbei
verdunkelt sich dieser ein exo planet im
orbit dieses sterns ist dann gefunden
dafür wird es den gesamten nehme scannen
und mehr als 200.000 sterne ins visier
nehmen die zahl der entdeckten
exoplaneten dürfte regelrecht
explodieren und die entdeckten planeten
wird dann das james webb space telescope
vst näher untersuchen
dieses riesige weltraum teleskop ist
nämlich speziell darauf vorbereitet
leben auf diesem planeten zu entdecken
anhand des sternenlichts dass durch die
atmosphäre eines solchen planeten zu uns
gelangt kann die atmosphäre analysiert
werden
das cabrio s t ist deutlich größer als
das hubble weltraumteleskop sucht zudem
im infraroten bereich dieser langwellige
bereich dringend besser aus allen teilen
des weltraums zu uns durch gibt es auf
den vom cabrio s&t untersuchten planeten
leben hat die atmosphäre eine bestimmte
zusammensetzung eines der ersten
untersuchungsobjekte wird trap ist wann
sein aber auch jetzt geht es schon los
denn bis man mit seinen sieben
exoplaneten und ryan davon in der
habitablen zone also in der sie leben
geben kann ist ein hoch interessantes
untersuchungsobjekt und deswegen
konzentriert sich jetzt das seti projekt
auf der b20 heißt search for
extraterrestrial intelligence also die
suche nach außerirdischer intelligenz
hier wird also nicht nach mikroben
sondern direkt nach und
menschenähnlichen leben gesucht als
erstes wurden alle radioteleskope des
allen telescope array es auf das
sternensystem ausgerichtet und noch
etwas ist besonders an
im projekt werden alle rohdaten
gespeichert um auch noch im nachhinein
fündig werden zu können
aber warum ist die gelegenheit gerade
jetzt so günstig die wissenschaftler vom
seti team haben festgestellt dass zwei
planeten in der habitablen zone so
zueinander stehen dass wenn sie
miteinander kommunizieren würden
entsprechende funkverkehr auch bei uns
laufen würde die verbindungslinie
zwischen den beiden planeten liegt
nämlich in der verlängerung genau in
einer achse mit der erde die forscher
erwarten dass wenn es dort intelligentes
leben geben würde diese dann auch auf
allen planeten in der habitablen zone
siedeln wirken und es dann auch zwischen
den planeten funkverkehr geben müsse die
chancen stehen also nicht schlecht hier
wirklich die ersten hinweise auf
intelligentes leben zu finden
wenn es passiert gibt es natürlich hier
sofort ein video und damit er das und
alle weiteren täglichen videos nicht
verpasst drückt mir hier ein abo
aufsaugen vergesst nicht mehr ein auf
die glocke zu geben und die besten
videos die er bisher verpasst habt die
gibt es hier bis dann bleibt dran